an 8 news now breaking news alert
breaking tonight police are
investigating a homicide in the central
valley thank you so much for joining us
tonight at 11 o'clock i'm sasha loftis
this happened on long valley drive right
near jones and vegas around 7 30 this
evening madison kimbrough is live on
scene with more tonight after a press
conference from metro police madison
yeah as you can see behind me it is an
active scene police arrived here shortly
after 7 30 this evening they found a man
in his mid to late 20's dead on scene
they say a group of individuals arrived
at the home it's unclear right now if
they tried to break in or not but there
was some type of struggle exchange
between the homeowner and the group when
shots were fired metro says the group
showed up with a long rifle possibly an
ak-47
that group of individuals entered the
house
armed with a long rifle possibly an
ak-47 at some point there was a struggle
inside the house and there was either an
exchange of gunfire or the resident of
the house
fired striking and killing one of the
other subjects
five to six people are said to be
involved and the homeowner is detained
according to police the homeowner knew
the man that was shot again as you can
see it's still a very active scene here
but we will continue to bring you
coverage on air and online reporting
live madison kimbrough live local now